d'abord les stars y les promenades et
car
j'ai un maître c'est superman mon chien
est le meilleur
mais il est pas terrible avec les autres
animaux franchement je trouve ça
dégoûtant comment ça dégoûtant tout
renifler c'est un des trucs hyper
jouissif pour un chien ça et aussi se
lécher partout par exemple moi bah je me
lève tout le temps mais ça explique la
laine
superbad je suis lui et tu vas tu
agenouillé devant moi espèces
à
qu'est-ce qui se passe
tu mets invulnérable je devrais être
beaucoup plus mort alors qu'il est non
on a tous des super pouvoirs
encore faire des réglages j'ai rien vu
ses ventes mon meilleur ami est en
danger et vous devez m'aider c'est bien
ce qu'on dit des chiens n'ont que notre
amour est inconditionnelle
on n'est qu'une bande d'animaux sur m
fixe
mais on est plus fort que ce que tu
crois
on va t'aider à retrouver ton en double
de m elle déploie le bouclier canin
c'est quoi un bouclier
en skis
ça doit être extrêmement douloureux
j'aurais pas pu avoir genre marteau
magique
[Musique]
à